أعتقد أه الولايات المتحدة أه
تدعم أه إسرائيل
جزئيا أه لأسباب سياسية داخلية
جزئيا
لأنها أه ترى ذلك وسيلة
أه
لمواجهة ما تعتبره صراع
حضارات كل الفاعلين في
أه الجانب
من
الدول الإسلامية نحن  تم تحذيرهم من قبل هنتنغتون
في عام 1992 من صراع
الحضارات أعتقد أن هذا
مثال ثاني أه
حيث يوجد بعد بين
الحضارات أه
وقد تم إبرازه
بالطريقة التي أه ردت بها أوروبا وأمريكا الشمالية
على حرب أوكرانيا بشكل مختلف
عن هذا  أه التجربة في غزة
أظهرت درجة
النفاق الأخلاقي وازدواجية
المعايير مما يدل على أن بعض
الجرائم محمية من
التدقيق الدولي وأعتقد أنها تمثل
جهد يائس للأمين العام
لجعل الأمم المتحدة بطريقة أو بأخرى
أه تدعو بشكل فعال إلى وقف إطلاق النار
و بالفعل  لقد نجحت أه رمزياً أعني أن
التصويت بأغلبية 13 مقابل 1 مع
تمديد واحد هو عرض حاسم جداً
في قضية صراع دولي وله
وزن معين خاصة لدى
الرأي العام الدولي مع
حكومات الجنوب العالمي وفي
العالم العربي و  لذلك لا ينبغي أن ينظر
إليها على أنها فاشلة لأنه
لم يتم اعتماد القرار
وسنرى ما سيحدث
بعد ذلك في أه الجمعية العامة
وفي
جميع أنحاء أه منظومة الأمم المتحدة هناك
أشياء أه يمكن أن تفعل ذلك
اليونيسيف الأجهزة المختلفة  الأمم المتحدة إن
منظومة الأمم المتحدة هي أكثر من مجرد
مجلس الأمن والجمعية العامة